oh we are winding down here in
indianapolis but it has been another
great day of incoming nfl players and
we're going to talk now to lsu national
champion edge rusher caleb on chase on
welcome to the program most valuable
player in the draft i heard you said
that over at the podium i'm intrigued by
that confidence what makes you think
you're the most valuable player in this
world i know i'm the most valuable
player in the draft i mean as far as
i got like i spoke before you want a guy
when you hire when you're starting up a
business do you want to hire people who
speak one language or you want to hire
people who speak three languages three
or four languages and i feel like i
speak three or four languages very well
i mean obviously you still got that one
language your first love language that
you know to like to be you know
regardless of the situation but i mean
the three or four languages that i speak
is just
is no different i mean i feel like a lot
of players in this draft that you can
feel like we're in the same position
they are a one-dimensional player and
once you stop that game is kind of a
less impactful person and i feel like if
you if you if any way on one of my game
cells get stopped i got three or four of
the games that are very that impact the
game very well what are they
specifically i mean my always
my best of the best will always be my
pass rush but i can drop in coverage and
cover any any receiver you want i feel
like i can play corner i got the good
feats in here for it um i feel like my i
played a run very well i'm always making
tacos for losses i feel like i had a
great amount this year even with the
with the amount of games i played i feel
like my special teams players is
tremendous i take pride in being on
special teams i definitely would vouch
for whatever team i go to to be a part
of the special teams where there's
plenty kickoff and as far as my football
iq i feel like that's the best of the
best i don't feel like there's no
there's no anybody in this drive better
than me and when it comes football like
you do you take more pride in your speed
or in your physicality my physicality a
lot of guys see me as a slim guy so
obviously they think they know that it's
a speed and when it comes to being a
powerful and standing up 350 guy 350
pound guys on the run block that's
something i take pride in is and it's
really just a mindset they don't have
anything to do with the physical gift
but have the mindset of being like
you're not going to move me you're not
going to put me on the ground you're not
going to bother me you're not going to
get this edge to reach me and i feel
like i live with that mindset throughout
the game who did you hit the hardest at
the college level
who did i hit the hardest at the college
level would probably have to be my
georgia southern game hit the running
back um on a quarterback draw i feel
like and it put him out after for the
rest of the game
did he make a sound what did he say what
was the sound um you definitely hit the
stadium go ooh
on the national tv so i feel like that's
definitely impactful when you hit a
stadium goal and then just saying i mean
don't wish this upon anybody but
obviously just having a big impactful
hit the ball coming out just having a
guy being helped off the field and just
lets you know i put some type of force
up on it what was the feeling for you
winning the national championship i'm
ecstatic
however though it still felt like it was
surreal i mean obviously going through a
long season i just felt like it was just
much more we had to do and i just i
still felt like at the end of the game
the defense didn't play as well as i
wanted them to i felt like it was just
still so much more we haven't we didn't
even reach our peak yet and but i mean
obviously they helped us out we came out
with a w but it was it was a surreal
feeling that we worked for and i'm glad
that we got it we used to hear about
rookies hitting the wall during their
first nfl season but yeah 15 games
there's no wall you've already been
through the wall exactly i mean
especially i know next year when you do
four preseason games and you have 16
games that's 20 games already then
including if you make the playoffs
that's the extra set of games so it's a
long season that's something that you
have to be definitely prepared for
physically and mentally but going
through a 15-game season already that
most don't ever go through i feel like
that's definitely helped the confidence
were you one of the guys smoking a cigar
in the locker room after the win not at
all
joe burrow was give me give me your
scouting report on joe burrow as a
teammate and as a quarterback in the nfl
great guy great guy i mean i think he
takes pride in being more of a team
player than anything and even after he
won the heisman he came back the next
day and his regular clothes like nothing
happened he was asking coach can he work
out but coach and coach didn't let him
do the workouts that day just to give
them a mental break from going through
all that just as far as but it's
something that i definitely want on my
team just as a quarterback who doesn't
feel the superb above anybody um you
every time you see him in the locker
room he's sitting with his legs
crisscross applesauce and he's just
trying just trying to learn something
new from us just being from an up north
guy and being around a bunch of guys
down south or trying to learn to lingo
our language or just the way we eat
things and just he's always somebody
who's willing to learn something i love
somebody like that your coach at orgeron
is a hell of a coach and a hell of a
character give me give me your best ed
orgeron story man
so
we take it back to recruiting i never
forget this and i kind of told him i
kind of told him it was shut down i was
going to take my talents to texas and
um kind of wasn't having that so
he set up a home visit i was on the way
to florida florida for official visit
and i was like coach we don't have time
for a home visit i'm about to head out
manny came in my house at four in the
morning knocking on the door while
everybody sleep and he made sure he got
his visit in and i was like coach we got
to head to the airport we got to be
there for six and he literally followed
me to the airport and walked me all the
way through tsa and just like bro we got
to have you please please and he's like
i know what to do with you i'm telling
you we're going to be the best of a duo
and i mean i felt like that would any
coach do all that is definitely more
than the job to them it's personal and i
feel like we gained the connection
throughout just being my first offer my
first college offer before i played it
down to varsity football awesome
it was it was well worth it who did you
play high school football with what was
this i played north north shore in
houston texas do we have uh highlights
if caleb on chase on in high school oh
there it is
tell us what's going on here oh my
that's what's going on oh geez there's
one of the languages
and there's two of the languages right
let's see what else we got that was
something uh was that gloves or was you
were you bare-handed no it was gloves it
was glass how about that spin move
oh what do we got here you remember this
game change the change direction oh geez
oh man that's drawing ooh in the stadium
get down what do we got here uh
you're just gonna bend around the corner
i'll i'll bend you
did you uh at some point during high
school you decided you had enough um as
far as football did you did you stop
playing at some point so i did i did uh
after my freshman my sophomore year i
told you that i felt like i wanted to be
a hoopster i felt like i had dreams of
being the best basketball player in the
world and
i definitely found out at the six four
pound fours don't get too hard
i mean i kind of had to understand a lot
of football coaches kept trying to get
me but i was like man i'm gonna make it
i'm gonna make it i mean i'm dunking i'm
not windmilling but i'm making it then
as far as even the basketball coaches
tell me like that might be your best
thing is i always always go in the game
i'm gonna get the five fouls worth it
you know a lot of guy who talking ain't
mess i'm gonna go get the five fouls and
come out the game with a great smile but
just transferring my my physicality and
my athletic ability to the game of
football that definitely helped me in
the best way were you the best
basketball player on the lsu football
team
i'm definitely vouching for that i mean
a lot of guys are good talent but i'm
the best basketball player all around i
got handles shots rebounds all that give
me the starting five
a basketball team from the lsu football
squad okay so we're going to go with
me
well all right let's go we got stephon
sullivan we're going to have him at the
big man
we want to go with thaddeus moss
to have him absolutely randy's son yes
he got to he's an athlete with the big
hands where's he going to be powerful
yeah you know stretch the floor and also
you have mia small forward you got
justin jefferson at
we have him at studentguard that's he
has the best shot on the team i can give
him man who's running point uh point
uh that's a good question i have i have
to reevaluate joe burrow
does he play basketball man joe do play
basketball so we'll put justin at the
point guard we'll have we're gonna have
joe at the two and then and and coach
coaches the team right coach is
definitely the motivational yeah all
game long
and five fouls to give five files to
give all right father get his tech but
it'll be definitely worth it well hey
man it's been great talking to you i can
tell you know we've talked to a lot of
guys the personalities jump out and
you're going to be a character in a good
way at the nfl level it's going to serve
you well and yeah i can tell you're
going to be a good teammate and you can
do all these different things and we
can't wait to see it happen caleb on
chase on folks
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports